John Carpenter's Halloween gave birth to the
modern slasher film, establishing virtually
every one of the genre's tropes and dramatically
announcing its director as a major new talent.
But even though you've seen it a dozen times,
there's a lot you might not know about one
of the greatest and most influential horror
films ever made.
Independent feature
It's now a classic horror film that paved
the way for everything that came after, but
Halloween wasn't exactly a major production.
The film was the brainchild of producer Irwin
Yablans who hired Carpenter because of his
strong visual style and ability to innovate
on a tight budget.
Yablans' idea was simple enough:
"Ah, a movie about babysitters in jeopardy
being terrorized and we'll do it all in one
night."
In fact, early in pre-production, the project
had the working title The Babysitter Murders.
Speaking with Entertainment Weekly, Carpenter
remembered,
"I was finishing [directing] a TV movie called
Someone's Watching Me! when Irwin Yablans
called and said, 'Why don't we set it on Halloween
night, in fact, why don't we call it Halloween?'"
Carpenter came up with the idea of the small
town with a dark secret that's revisited on
Halloween night.
He and Debra Hill wrote the script, as Hill
explained to Fangoria:
"We wrote the whole thing in three weeks.
Then we just had to find the right actors."
Casting Laurie
Especially important was casting the part
of Laurie Strode, the movie's heroine.
Tommy Lee Wallace, Carpenter's friend and
one of the film's editors, explained to Consequence
of Sound:
"This was a time that women were asserting
their rights like never before, and Debra
was a very assertive woman.
No way she was going to have a weeping violet
type as her heroine."
Carpenter, who didn't watch television, had
never seen Jamie Lee Curtis' work on the series
Operation Petticoat, but Hill was convinced
she'd be perfect for the role.
One small detail was all it took to convince
Carpenter, Curtis also happened to be the
daughter of Janet Leigh, perhaps the original
scream queen, whose shower had been rudely
interrupted in the 1960 classic Psycho.
Pulling out all the tricks
The film was shot with a $320,000 budget.
If it doesn't look particularly low-budget,
it's because Carpenter was a master at making
something from nothing.
As there was no room in the budget for a costume
department, the entire cast's wardrobe was
purchased on the cheap at local department
stores.
Michael Myers' mask was crafted from a repurposed
William Shatner mask, purchased from a local
costume store for $1.98 and painted white.
Also enabling them to keep the budget in check,
the filming location for the Myers' house
was an abandoned property, owned by a church.
And although the film was shot in Pasadena,
California, it was set in Illinois, so Carpenter
evoked the feel of autumn in the Midwest by
using the same several trash bags full of
painted leaves for exterior scenes, scattering
them around whatever street they were currently
shooting on, only to collect them all to be
re-used in the next shot.
The minimalist aesthetic carried over to post-production;
Carpenter wrote the film's classic theme in
only an hour, and scored the entire film himself
in just three days.
Working for peanuts
Another way to keep the budget low was to
pay very little.
As the biggest name in the cast, Donald Pleasence
got a flat fee of $20,000, while little-known
star Curtis received only $8,000.
Carpenter's buddy Nick Castle was paid the
princely sum of $25 per day to portray "The
Shape," as Michael Myers is called in the
credits, and Carpenter himself took only $10,000
plus a small percentage of the film's profits,
which ended up working out for him.
He said:
"I can't remember exactly how much money I
made off the film.
I do remember getting one check for over a
million dollars, that wasn't bad."
Limited release
Halloween debuted on October 25, 1978 in a
single city, Kansas City, Missouri.
As the buzz started to grow, national critics
started paying attention.
The great Roger Ebert concluded his sparkling
review with a warning that should have had
any horror fan sprinting out the door to buy
tickets:
"I'd like to be clear about this.
If you don't want to have a really terrifying
experience, don't see Halloween."
The film went on to gross an astonishing $47
million, reigning for over a decade as the
most profitable independent film ever made.
Not as gory as you think
Despite how you might remember it, Halloween
includes virtually no onscreen gore.
Carpenter's expert use of slowly building
tension, spooky imagery, and perfectly deployed
jump scares left audiences with the impression
that what they had just seen must have been
crazy violent in order to be that disturbing.
But that wasn't Carpenter's take.
"I wanted something deadly simple and something
that would just eat at you a little bit."
Hill alluded to this in production notes for
1981's Halloween 2, saying,
"People don't seem to realize that we showed
next to no blood in the first picture.
You think you're seeing a lot more than we're
showing you."
The almost-anthology
Carpenter and Hill never envisioned even a
single sequel, let alone a franchise.
Carpenter explained to Deadline:
"I didn't think there was any more story,
and I didn't want to do it again."
Instead of finding ways to bring Michael Myers
back, Carpenter and Hill had the idea to tell
a different story with each new Halloween
film, making it an ongoing horror anthology
series.
Halloween 2's tepid box office convinced producers
to give it a shot, and the result, 1982's
Halloween 3: Season of the Witch, instantly
polarized horror fans everywhere.
Many fans wanted Michael Myers back and they
got their wish six years later, although the
sequels and rebooted series that followed
provided mostly diminishing returns, with
one exception.
Halloween H20: 20 Years Later ignored previous
sequels and served as a direct sequel to Halloween
2.
Ironically, Halloween is set to receive the
same retcon treatment again.
The Halloween reboot scheduled for 2018 will
serve as a direct sequel to the original,
with Carpenter serving as executive producer
and providing the score, and Jamie Lee Curtis
returning to play Laurie Strode one more time.
"Michaaaaeeeel."